pumping out up to a trillion times more
energy than our son
if you have a close encounter with a
supermassive black hole you got to have
to go through a very dangerous
environment
you have to survive the intense
radiation you have to survive the jet
so how two stars form around such
violence astronomers find a black hole
which might hold the key to how the
Milky Way got its first stars there's a
really exciting discovery of a
supermassive black hole the kind we
normally only find at the hearts of
galaxies sitting out there by itself
with no galaxies around it
this thing's shining like crazy so we
know it's gobbling up gas he0 four five
zero two nine five eight sits five
billion light years from Earth a black
hole with a huge jet this jet is
smashing into dust and gas in its
neighboring galaxies you'd think it
would destroy the galaxies but instead
it's helping to build it it's next to a
big galaxy and this big galaxy is
forming stars like crazy
so we think what's going on is because
of the stuff coming off of the black
hole as it's growing their stars being
triggered to form in this galaxy next to
it the black hole's colossal jet is the
spark needed to create a star Factory
the black hole is emitting radiation and
when this radiation runs into all the
gas in the galaxy
this causes the gas to clump together
and new stars get made
direct evidence that black holes can
create stars hg 0 4 5 0 - 2 9 5 8 might
be a look back into the milky way's past
our galaxy's supermassive black holes
violent feasting sparks stars into life
these stars are drawn by the black holes
huge gravity and orbit building the
galaxy the black hole could actually
stimulate star formation so some people
believe that the very fact that we have
galaxies is due to the fact that we have
a raging black hole at the center which
helps to initiate star formation it's
possible that the black hole could have
created many of the stars we see in our
sky today
including the one star we can't live
without
our son